yeah what i was saying off the top was
um
obviously as we expected yesterday
the sports community really everybody
but the sports community in particular
reacted to the indictment
related to but not in direct response to
brianna taylor's killing um
yesterday in louisville and particularly
nba players we knew they would have a
lot to say
uh before the heats up this game last
night so after the game though
bam adebayo he not only dedicated the
game
and dedicated the win to brianna but he
also said that they tried to
channel their anger into the game so i
want to start with that word with you
and ask you
how have you been dealing with your
anger all of us are angry
how have you been dealing with your
anger since yesterday
so it's a great question mike it's a
work in progress
it's a work in progress i i can't say
i've been
dealing with it successfully because
throughout the night
uh and throughout the day today there's
just always another aspect of it and
always another layer that comes to my
mind
that makes me angry or makes me
disappointed
i think that's a word too disappointed
because
i i was thinking about this today and
it's a great question man i'm going to
answer your question in a second but i
was thinking about this
on the way in for people in this
business the journalism side of things
he always talk about objectivity
i know we have it we'll have a debate on
this another time
i don't believe that objectivity truly
exists
i think we're all subjective trying to
be fair uh
the people who are doing it right but
nobody's truly objective the only body
the only person's really objective is a
robot
you have feelings you have an experience
that brought you
to the point that you're in right now
and so that all of that matters
and it colors the way you look at things
but this is not the time but that being
said mike this is not the time for
anybody to be objective it's not the
time for anybody to kind of stand
back and hey let's look at both sides
there are
no both sides there's no both sides of
this
and i have uh i wrote down today
it's time to be an advocate and that was
just a that's just an
umbrella i got all kinds of things under
that umbrella
i ida b wells is a big name because ida
b wells was going through the south
looking around and seeing people be
lynched
she was looking at lynchings and they
were not being dealt with nobody was
held accountable nobody was talking
about it so
she was a journalist who said no i'm
gonna talk about this i'm not gonna be
objective there's no other side
there there's uh there are monstrosities
happening
in this so-called democ democracy these
yet to be
united states as james baldwin said so
i'm gonna talk about it
and so i think that's where we are now
everybody has got to declare
where do you stand let me know where you
stand
if you are if you are against this if
you have a problem with this
thanks for letting me know so that
that's where i am
mike and as far as channeling anger
lots of ways lots of ways on one hand
you know i i pray on it i've been
praying on it
for for months just on on the state that
we're in the the chaotic
state that we're in as a country and as
a
global society that's one and secondly i
go back and forth and i'd love to know
how you feel about this because i know
how
how close you were to your grandparents
and just like i i i
was with mine and my grandfather
uh grew up in selma grew up in selma
alabama early 1900's
and he got out and so he got out
and if that doesn't seem like a big deal
you have to understand
what the sharecropping system was at
that time
like there was really no freedom you had
to sneak out of there
because if you were in a sharecropping
situation and you left
and you were black they would hunt you
down so he got out of selma and he was
always talking about that being
independent and
in fighting for what's right and having
integrity
and so i think about my grandparents
and what they went through so as angry
as i am
and as dis as disappointed as i am i
keep saying
i can't i can't cave in i can't give in
because
i owe them something i owe that entire
generation those generations
i owe them my effort i owe them
my resources i owe them my intellect
everything i've got
i got to give it to them because they
have they've done so much to put us in
this position
and the generations to come for that
matter um
i want to stay with that that that word
and that theme of anger
um you know as i and and many others
like yourself
try to process it try to manage it try
to deal with it and figure out what are
the most
constructive and productive ways to
channel it
um and you referenced james baldwin
earlier and a lot of people are familiar
with the quote
negro and relatively conscious
in this country is to be in a state of
rage almost all the time but i want to
read the quote in its entirety
because as as as every as with
everything that james baldwin said
it was powerful and it was important the
man didn't waste words
um so let me read the entire quote to be
a negro in this country and to be
relatively conscious
is to be in a state of rage almost
almost all the time
and in one's work and part of the rage
is this it isn't only what is happening
to you but it's what's happening all
around you
and all of the time in the face of the
most extraordinary and criminal
indifference
indifference of most white people in
this country and their ignorance
now since this is so it's a great
temptation
to simplify the issues under the
illusion that if you simplify them
enough
people will recognize them i think this
illusion is very dangerous because
in fact it isn't the way it works
a complex thing can't be made simple
you simply have to try to deal with it
in all its complexity
and hope to get that complexity across
and the reason i wanted to share that
whole thing because a common response
you've seen and is true
since yesterday is that briana taylor
deserved better
and there's no question that she did but
does everybody feel that way
does everybody actually feel like she
deserved better
do enough people feel like she deserved
better or do people feel like she got
what she deserved and here's what i mean
by that
yeah tell me because think about
think about the law and how it was
interpreted and think about the reaction
to the lack of an indictment the lack of
even a mention quite honestly
in the indictment of her killing of her
murder okay
the cops were justified
when they broke in when they barged into
her house
they were justified to use deadly force
because her boyfriend shot at them first
that's crazy the narrative has it's
almost has been it's almost been like
people are trying to paint it as though
they were bonnie and clyde
and when the cops broke in they knew it
was the cops and decided to get in the
shootout with the cops and you know why
that story flies
is because it's always believable when
it comes to black people
that we are out of control that we are
inherently violent
and that we are a threat that needs to
be neutralized
it's believable because whether whether
it's the boyfriend or the ex-boyfriend
whatever
the circumstances is they got one
witness according to daniel cameron
to corroborate that the police announced
himself so okay it wasn't a new knock
warrant
and then once once daniel cameron
thinking it was an intruder
exercise his legal right to defend
himself
the police had a right to fire off 32
shots to defend themselves
and let me say another thing it's always
and i respect the job police officers do
don't get me wrong
but it's always well the police have a
right to go home to their families
it's never black people in this case
brianna taylor
have a right to be in their homes and
live
in their homes and go home to their
families
so in other words police could defend
themselves yeah but the boyfriend
couldn't defend himself
it is always just we are always denied
justice because it's always justifiable
to brutalize black and brown bodies
it's always made to seem like we had it
coming it's always made to seem like we
deserved it
and so that's what i'm talking about
when it comes to the indifference
and the ignorance it's always the story
around
our criminality and we have to be
punished we have to be arrested
charged tried and executed right there
on the spot and this is no different
mike let me back up for a second here
okay
and i agree with you and and thank you
for sharing that james baldwin quote
that's one of my literary fathers
um as as a young writer i tried uh
unsuccessfully i tried to write like
james baldwin
i remember reading his novel great novel
another country and trying to
to mimic his his style and his
flourishes it's a good aim though right
very ambitious
all right so let's back up let's back up
though you mentioned uh
the police on this raid
breaking into the apartment
why was this a good idea at midnight
let's start there
why was this a good idea at midnight
yeah and and what what were you trying
to accomplish do you think i mean do you
think that
the person you're trying to get because
you got bad information
you probably should have talked to some
some investigative reporters at the
louisville courier journal maybe they
have better sources than you do
and you think that the boyfriend is
going to be there or you think this
this pot of gold they thought the money
was there he's like that brianna taylor
was holding some money for her
ex-boyfriend and the rumor was
that the money was in the apartment they
found they found nothing
so the ex-boyfriend's not there money's
not there
they don't find anybody violent but
let's back it up
why is it a good idea to go there at
that hour
and to use those means that that
methodology so the whole thing
is broken and as i said to you before
mike i'm not trying to minimize
a a drug lord or drug use or a career
a career involved in dealing drugs
selling drugs
but they responded as if this was
somebody
on the fbi's most wanted list and they
had to bring
everything they had every every single
resource like they were going to this
apartment
come on so i that's why i said earlier
you've got to declare where you stand
with me declare where you stand
and then we can keep it moving but
there's no there's no
like intellectual oh well you know have
you considered this
no no i haven't that's what i'm saying
right
it's like i don't want to play that game
let's
let's look at the evidence look at look
at look at our ex-boyfriend and look
like okay it's all again nobody's
condoned in any kind of criminal
activity
but we have seen murderers mass
murderers
dylann roof taken alive
treated with respect it with humanity
how about this kid
the 17 year old kid kyle rittenhouse
right
okay like and not
disregarded and disrespected in death
and put on trial and death we were
criminalized on the spot and then
criminalized in death well
he had drugs in his locker or you know
he got suspended from school
or it runs in his family it all
perpetuates the notion
that by nature we're violent and have to
be policed
aggressively and that story always flies
law and order
is a dog whistle it is cold but we are
getting these black people in line
we are saving you in your suburbs from
these black people that is the code word
that politicians use that's the coded
language law and order that's what that
means people of color black people
hispanics
that's what that means do not get it
twisted but let me go to the complexity
part of this
because we have narrowed this
conversation down
and simplified it to the tip of the
iceberg i keep saying the extreme
manifestation of systemic racism is
police brutality
for every brianna taylor there are
thousands of black women
who are facing oppression and racism and
discrimination in the workplace
who are making 66 of what every white
man makes for the same job
there are thousands of black people who
are being denied
the right to to to excel professionally
because ceos like the one at wells fargo
thinks that there's a a a lack of
not enough a big enough pool of black
talent to choose from
you know it's it starts with educa we
talk about education is the answer okay
let's talk about the education
and the conditioning that these people
are receiving
there's the white supremacist system of
education that we're taught in this
country
that the highest that the the height
that our leadership at the highest
levels in this country they're trying to
eradicate
any kind of teaching about critical race
theory in order to combat
us dealing with the original sins of
this country
let's talk about the education and
conditioning
that leads people to get to a point
as an adult whether you're running a
company or whether you're on the police
force
to feel like people of color
specifically black and brown people
black and brown men and women
have to be treated differently why is
that the default
why is it the default why does why does
saying i fear for my life
whether you whether he's armed or
whether he's carrying a bag of skittles
and iced tea
why does i feared for my life why is
that always okay
and there's no way you could disprove
that but there seems to be a
different level of fear when it comes to
us
that's that's what's being taught that's
what people are being conditioned
to believe from a young age and they
grow up and exercise that power
in everyday life you know it's going to
be
it's going to be interesting mike
you